all right guys we've got the sun up
we've got a great last day of
august on its way and boy beautiful 70s
it's mild out there
we've got humidity that's low between
about 10 and 12 percent
for valley neighborhoods that feels
great look at all the 70s from aliante
down to the strip seven hills at 77. 75
for centennial hills and boy it just
feels good mountains edger at 74 degrees
you can't beat that although i think
over the next couple of mornings after a
cold front moves through
we don't want to be cooler than this i
think we're going to cool off even more
71 at red rock
and in the trump valley this morning 77
in boulder city
laughlin still a little warm in laughlin
look for thunderstorms today southern
clark county could actually see
a little monsoon moisture a reminder
that today is the last day
for the summer watering schedule so then
you'll have to set your sprinkler clocks
to three days a week
and while the time of day watering
restrictions go away
after today i would not be watering
during the day
because we have quite a warm-up coming
back for labor day weekend
just really wasteful and not good for
your grass to be watering during the
heat of the day
you know september can stay pretty hot
so keep watering in the overnight hours
and early early morning before it gets
hot big thunderstorms and showers moving
through the eastern u.s
look at the southern plains and in the
upper midwest while we'll see the
monsoon moisture bubble up again in the
afternoon and then
even closer to the colorado river in
southern clark county today
again we'll be looking for thunderstorms
there but not for las vegas
we're not looking for storms today a
cold front that will slide through
southern nevada in the desert southwest
by tomorrow
will bring a cool down it will be a
brief one but at least it'll be a break
in the heat for a little bit
and then feeding into the monsoon
moisture is the leftovers of
tropical storm iselle moving up the
gulf of california 103 sunshine and
southerly breezes to about 20 miles an
hour today
tomorrow the winds turn to out of the
north and that's what's going to help
break down the triple digits to double
digits 97 tomorrow
and then we're right back to triple
digits again and man they take off with
a vengeance
check out the temps for labor day
weekend 108 109
if you have outdoor plans make sure
they're cool ones because
it is going to be some pretty big heat
for the weekend